Android wear notifications are the
easiest way to get started in the world
of wearables.
If you've got an Android
app with a notifications,
they all ready work on the watch.
If you've all ready enhanced
your notification with actions,
such as next or previous.
This is even better, and
also automatically works with
no additional work required.
You can take things further with Wear's
specific functionality that make
your notifications even richer
experiences on the wrist.
Stacks, which are like
inbox style notifications,
now you can deliver multiple
items in a single bundle.
Pages are for showing multiple screens
of information on the same topic.
But, remember to stay glanceable.
Replies.
Now replies allow the user to
respond directly from the wearable
with their voice.